thank you well I'd like to thank my dad
for inviting me here than mcgovern for
hosting this it's a real privilege
particularly because I was a postdoc
here at MIT and in fact three out of the
ten panel members were my contemporaries
at the time so it's like a mini reunion
with me which is great fun
I spent most of my time thinking about
sort of low-level sensory motor control
so you know when you want to handle some
object such as a can you have to learn
some computer learn some country better
go get some control policy as a
functions of state of the limb such as
position and velocity and this control
policy may have some interesting shape
now because of noise in the sensory
inputs you may not quite where you are
on the surface so you do some clever
Bayesian inference for example to
estimate that and even if you knew where
you were on that surface because of
variability in the motor output and
there may be problems producing a little
correct control but that's at a very low
level for a single task but if you think
about things more generally not
everything is a simple cat and if we
think about the next level up tasks can
vary in terms of their parameters so you
can deal with cans of different sizes
and shapes and maybe if you deal with
them you have to learn for example how
to modulate this control policy for
different cans sizes and if you were a
good Bayesian learn something about the
distribution of possible cans but again
not everything in this world's a can and
in fact there are different structures
in the world for example there are cans
or a power tools different families of
objects which might have different sort
input out relationships and required
fundamentally different controllers now
most of the tasks we do in the lab are
fitfully confused for example structures
versus parameters if you learn one task
it's hard to separate the structure from
the parameters so the only way you can
begin to learn about those is by
experiencing many examples of particular
structure today what I want to try and
cover is issues to do with how you might
learn things about structures and
parameters or how you extract priors
from the world and particularly
techniques for extracting natural price
and then when I move on to talking about
learning internal models in terms of
structural learning and temporal context
that there's a time at the very end I
might talk a little bit about
decision-making
okay here's how I think about internal
models okay and I think this view of and
models is exactly consistent with all
the views you've had so for just more
general so we can think in general that
the world generates a data for us and
has structure so in general there's a
true generative model in the world which
generates things make objects features
states of the body and given the
generation of those objects features or
states the physics of our senses in our
body generates some sensory stimuli and
these distributions may well be
probabilistic distributions because
things may be stochastic so that's the
real world but what about inside the
brain will it be very useful to the
brain to have some knowledge of these
true properties of the world and so what
I think of as internal models is things
which capture aspects of those true
situations so we have for example a
modern era scientist at our brain which
make us how we expect to see objects
features or states of the world and
another model which might tell us given
a particular state of the world what the
probability of different sensory inputs
is so these are two sorts of forms of
internal representations and the point
is if you have these then if you get a
particular sensory stimulus you can use
this thing here which we call the prior
to turn this arrow around and generate
what we want which is the property of a
particular state of the world given our
sensory input the percept now this may
sound like something completely
different from all this evans copy
predictive ford model motor control but
it's actually identical it's just more
general in that reference copy is just
one part of things you can use to
predict or estimate States now you might
say well that's all very well how much
evidence is there in neuroscience
research a Bayesian internal models well
the answer is and there's a lot for
example back 10 years ago a nice review
about object perceptions Bayesian
inference the wave to see if the world
is beige what about motor control well
we wrote some reviews saying you can
explain some features of sensory motor
control in a Bayesian framework what
about higher level things Josh Tenenbaum
has shown very nicely with Tom Griffiths
inductive learning and reasoning are all
very Bayesian and what about attention
well clearly Bayesian inference theory
of attention don't worry about that but
what about diseases you ask me don't
worry schizophrenia is a Bayesian
disease there must be some things this
world which aren't Bayesian what about
don't worry mirror neurons they're
Bayesian as well but that's fine so
humans are bayesian but surely animals
they count Bayesian what about ours it's
all fine
owls behavior predicted by Bayesian
inference well that's all very good but
surely it's just the whole system not
little small parts of it like neurons
neurons can't be patient well they can
be Bayesian so
Bayesian model predicts responsive axons
of molecular gradients everything is
Bayesian internals every level in fact
there's so many internal models of the
brain I no longer think of the arm brain
having internal model we arm I now think
of the arm being external model of the
brain so the Bayesian world is retaken
over but there's some issues what other
natural priors we have about the world
how do we acquire these natural prize
and what are they well one would hope
the priors are adapted to natural
statistics to be of any use and so there
many studies where people record the
crew statistics and show that people
behave as though they've internalized it
and this is a nice example from Tom
Griffith and Josh Tenenbaum where you
ask more questions about lifespans and I
won't go into it just in case you may
cover this but you've given a true
distribution of lifespans you can show
that people have some understanding of
that distribution when they answer
questions or you can go try to measure
people's prize for simple scalar prize
for example here's a measure of the
price will have the speeds of objects
his speed versus the relative
probabilities this dashed line would be
a Gaussian distribution this is what's
measured from a subject showing it has
some heavier tails or you can measure
the price per half of the way light
shine from and like the kind of shine
above from just above and from the left
or you could do studies of simple
low-level psychophysics like we've done
and this is a study actually which you
induce dimensioned where we measured the
prior of a vision motor transformations
but you can even go to more cognitive
domains for example for example this is
a nice one from Sanborn and Griffis
where they try to measure something
about the cognitive representations of
categories of different sorts of animals
but this sort of task is really limited
to one task at a time so there's a
problem with all these studies in that
priors are really a bunch of free
parameters in these studies which you
can go and fit to the data and a lot of
critics of the Bayesian approach will
say whatever touch come up with of
course you can construct up
prior which will make us fit their data
and therefore it's just a curve fitting
exercise and the true advantage of pride
is that they should generalize across
tasks and almost all they start at the
bottom actually this one here which
through a simple prior only look at
priors within a single simple task so
the girl of the study I'm gonna tell you
about is to really ask the question for
high level priors oh do we have priors
across tasks or are we learning things
in a handcrafted way and the reason this
is important it maps on to two
fundamental ways we can learn about the
world so there's discriminative learning
I can show you these faithless
parametrizing some space and I can say
learn these are male versus female and
you might learn some line in the space
which separates and when I give you
another path such as old with young you
learn another line so you're doing some
sort of regression or super support
vector machine to separate out in this
task space for different tasks the
alternative to that is a generative
model where you first learn something
about the fundamental properties of
faces are sort of generative model of
how faces develop and then that's the
first stage of processing before you go
on to apply that same underlying
representation to many tasks so the
critical thing is that discriminative
learning will lead to a task dependent
representation whereas generative leads
to a task independent underlying
representation which we think of as the
prior and so I'm gonna tell you about a
technique we've developed with Matti
L'Engle called cognitive tomography
which aims to extract high dimensional
priors from low dimensional measurements
so like tomography we're going to take
very low dimensional measurements and
we're going to take try dimensional
representations that's the idea one
reviewers hate this term I rather like
it um okay so we're gonna work with
faces I'm really out of my comfort zone
here I I'm not a face person I'm not a
vision person but it was a nice example
to look at what the technique works and
so what we take is we take a well-known
dataset from balls or where they've
scanned in many many faces and they've
worked out the physical structure the
faces and done principal components
analysis on structures so this is the
first principal component second
principal component this is - for two
plus four standard deviations in face
space and so this shows you the corners
of the face space what we might imagine
is that a subject might have some prize
subjective distribution over face is
shown by the sort of grayscale here and
that's our prior what we can do is give
them a task we can show them they say
pairs of faces as a stimulus and we get
into the bus responses one or two very
low dimensional responses and what we
want to do is typically extract this
subjective distribution from the
stimulus and responses and to do that we
have to have a hypothesis how they're
going to use the subjective distribution
and the stimuli to produce response and
we also could include a whole bunch of
what we call nuisance parameters such as
noises and biases and the perception and
decision-making
now we're not interested in this at all
so what we're gonna do is effectively
from this ideal observer inverted and
given the stimulus and the response
we're gonna factor out the noise and vs.
and estimate this distribution using
machine learning techniques now if you
want to know about these techniques
you'll be very happy to there with no
the reviewers push the supplementary
material up to 26 pages of validation
'lest techniques and controls so you're
welcome to again read that it's it's
long-winded but we've tested that out a
lot official data in various ways that
it's validated okay here are the two
tasks the first task with a very simple
one familiarity we choose two faces
randomly distributed among our faces and
we ask which ones more familiar okay
very simple task and the second task is
we show three faces and we say which
one's the odd one out now these may
sound like similar tasks to you but
they're actually fundamentally very
different this one requires you to
compare each face with some internal
representation of familiar faces this
one requires you to compare the three
faces to each other to choose the one
which is how about at least like the
other two now we can model these in very
simple ways given a subjective
distribution here it's going to be very
clear the one which has a higher
probability and your subjective
distribution will on average be more
familiar subject and noises and
perception and noises and
decision-making and lapses of
concentration when it comes to this task
care we use something from the from Josh
Tenenbaums work where effectively we
assume that what generating these
straight faces is you choose two faces
from the distribution and then one of
them is corrupted produce two other
faces here and these two other faces are
more similar than the one over here so
you have three different hypotheses as
to which one was generated and not
corrupted and that's the odd one out
so we give a thousand trials of each of
these tasks to ten subjects and then we
extract their posterior of the
subjective distribution and here's one
example for one of our subjects as you
can see the underlying distribution is
highly structured it's not a simple
Gaussian in this two-dimensional space
and if we look then at another subject
doing the same task we fear strikingly
different subjective distribution so
across two subjects we get very
different distributions extracted from
this task on the other hand if we look
at another tasks in the same subjects
this was familiar if this was odd one
out we get very similar distributions
across tasks but very different across
subjects if we look at all ten subjects
what we see is often very idiosyncratic
among each subject but very similar
among the tasks now you'll notice as I
gave down this this they become more
dissimilar and there's a good reason for
that we can measure for each subject how
consistent they are by repeating the
first hundred trials they deal with each
task and the last hundred and a random
order and random positioned to see how
consistently answer the same way and
what I've done is I rank tiles ten
subjects from most consistent to the
least consistent and if studies have
very non consist it's actually quite
hard to extract their subjective
distribution and that shows here here's
the average consistency fully consistent
it's very unconscious tintin the
difference between these two measured
about the Jensen Shannon divergence
decreases as you become more consistent
so it suggests that we have a subjective
distribution which is used across two
tasks now the real proof of the pudding
is prediction this looks impressive but
can we take data and predict new
responses what we can do is we can take
each subjects data set split it in half
many times fit our model and then
predict the other half of their data
within a trial and that's shown here
here's the familiarity task and here's
our ten subjects ranked from the most of
these consistent here's chance in our
prediction and were significantly above
chance and all these cases in terms are
but if you predict their responses in
the other half the dataset similarly for
the odd one out task were above chance
by a long way
how close to optimal are we well it
turns out we can calculate that because
given their consistency scores we can
know what the true upper bound is are
not ability to predict and what I'm
showing you here for all our subjects is
the consistency score and this boundary
is how well we should ever be able to
predict given how consistent they are
and effectively we're very close to the
upper boundary particularly for the
familiarity and we're close to it for
the odd one out task what about taking
the prior we get from this and applying
it this other task to predict the cross
task and it turns out we do very well on
that as well so having extracted
distributions familiarity we can predict
by the one out and simply fit a code one
out we can do a good job of predicting
familiarity and this just shows you the
group data again within tasks across
task prediction we can also ask how
important of the find details of these
distributions if we fit our distribution
and then we replace it with a bivariate
Gaussian of the same mean and covariance
through a moment Matchett and we use
this now to predict we do significantly
worse particularly within tasks and if
we take a state-of-the-art predictor a
Gaussian process classifier and just
apply it directly to the data to try and
predict subjects data we actually do
better than that
for both our situations if you get more
data the Gaussian process will win in
the end but with limited data fitting
with the priority that's better and more
than that we can show that in this odd
one out task subjects are not picking
the most familiar or least familiar that
fits the data very poor so it suggests
that priors for faces are highly
structured subject-specific and
predictive behavior across tasks and the
fact they're invented crossed our three
suggests strongly they're acquired by a
generative process rather than a
discriminative process now we think this
technique can be extended to higher
dimensions than the other tasks and we
think it's an exciting opportunity to
sort of link in to with neurophysiology
and also to imaging work with this one
of the tricky things about extending it
is as you go to higher dimensions you
need a lot more training data from the
subjects and so one way to get around
that is to have active learning at the
moment the algorithms would fit this are
too slow to fit between each trial of a
subject and so with new machine learning
techniques we hope to be able to choose
the best next data samples before the
subjects to extract the
most amount of information so I want to
move back now to my homeland of motor
control and talk a bit about learning
internal models we've been very
interested in the idea of structural
learning the idea that it's important to
learn about structures of the world
separate from the parameters of the
world and so we think about structural
learning in the following way when you
learn to ride a couple of bicycles you
can pretty much write any bicycle even
if they've got different sort of shapes
and parameters or wheel sizes and it
could be the way you do this is when you
learn to ride a bicycle you have to set
up some parameters in your head be they
synaptic weights and here in red for
some very high dimensional space is the
blue bicycle and the orange bicycle the
pink bicycle now if you have to explore
the entire parameter space it's gonna be
very slow if you can learn that all
bicycles learn a lower dimensional
manifold here I'm showing you one
dimension but could be a
multi-dimensional then effectively you
can restrict your exploration along that
particular manifold so that when you
come to a bike you can effectively have
a privileged superhighway to zoom
between the parameters for these
different bicycles okay and if you have
other bicycle like objects which look
similar and share the same structure
well it's it's bad news they lie off
your structure and they'll be rather
tall generalization between the two so
how can we test the idea that structures
are important well one way to do this is
to use something which is very common in
motor control and that's interference if
you learn a task for example a visual
motor rotation or prism or a robot
pushing on your arm your arrow will tend
to come down with time and if you same
people away for minutes two weeks later
they'll come back and carry on pretty
much with a left off so they can store
motor memories over long periods of time
on the other hand if they do a task and
you send them away four minutes two
weeks and bring them back and give them
the opposite task about opposite tasks I
mean if the prism deviated their vision
to the lesson as I said to the right if
the robot initially pushed the left and
I push them to right you see they're
worse than they would have been had they
never experienced this first task and so
we think of that as anterograde
interference and then if you send away
from in its two weeks bring them back
and give them the first task while
they'd forgotten it okay so this all
that TAS tends to wipe out the first
task retrograde interference now the way
you can think about this is here are the
two toss his task and the blue toss it
just two spots in space there's no
nothing that links them up as part of a
structure they're just two examples of
things out there so when you learn the
red task over here you're very far from
the blue and go to the blue you're very
far from the red and vice-versa and our
hypothesis is maybe we can make this
part of a structure by effectively
joining them up okay so if they can
experience join these two things up they
might learn a path between them which
will allow them to generalize rapidly
along the structure do is very simple
when we use visual aid rotations like
you've heard before you move in one
direction we rotate visual feedback and
we can change the rotation on every
trial if we want to so we have a very
simple experiment control group form 800
trials under veridical feedback just
like you do computer mouse very boring
we then give them a block of six degree
rotations to the right 60 to the left 60
to the right and we see what we expect
to see the errors big here and it
reduces over the 50 or so trials when we
then go to the opposite one they have a
very big error because they were
pointing the wrong way they relearn it
when we go back to the original one
where they forgotten most of it okay so
the typical interference we see but then
we have our group where we try to impose
structural learning on them and we do
that by for these eight hundred trials
at the beginning giving them a new
random rotation sample uniformly from
minus ninety to ninety every eight
trials
it's horrible to be a subjective
experiment it's like using our computer
mouse with some rotates the mouse in
your hand randomly every eight times you
point with people get very frustrated we
pay them lots of money to sit there and
they'll do it and what people think is
happening is here's minus 60 here's + 60
and we're linking them up through sort
of the rotations are sort of low
dimensional representation in that space
now having done that when we go to our
plus 60 what we see is with a few trials
they're down at really braced line
performance really rapid now they've
learnt this now better than our control
groups in theory that sort of further
away from the blue now but yet when we
switch and they don't know when the
switch is going to come we're in a few
trials they're down at baseline again
we switch back again within one or two
trials they're down at baseline
suggesting that having experienced the
structure we see very rapid switching
between these opposing things now the
motor control aficionados in the room
will know they've been two recent papers
one from shad Mis group one from the
Zaki's group saying you can explain all
this with very simple low-level models
but the shad main model says all you're
learning is to be more sensitive to all
errors because you experience lots of
errors and if you're faster to adapt and
the exactly one says oh to store all
this memory to store the water memory
and you can just reply them when they
come back out well there's a problem I
think with both those models it's
because they basically fit the state and
if we all we done with this that would
be fine but what they ignore is the
critical control we actually did to test
whether it was really a structure you're
learning or whether the experience of
the perturbations or the errors so the
other problem of their studies they're
all one-dimensional and it's basically
impossible to have an interesting
structure on one dimension and you put
the representation to one dimension
everything becomes very easy so the
critical control is that we have a group
who explains 800 trials where again they
get a new perturbation every eight
trials but for 10% of those they get
minus 60 lots of experience of this and
temperately get plus 64 a lot experience
of these two and the other 80% they get
a combination of rotation as shearing
and scaling so a really horrible visual
most transformation that's the way we
think about this is we ensure they get
lots of experience here lots here but
there's no low dimensional path between
the two it just covers a whole vision
motor rotation space so there's no
structure linking them up in that sense
so what we find in this group is they
figure they perform no differently than
our control group they learn nothing
about the structure they could have
stored all these things in memory as
well so suggested was that after
structured but random learning we see
structure specific facilitation and we
see structure specific interference
reduction and we think structured
learning is actually important part of
life I think most of what we do as
adults is parametric learning I know
about properties of tools but I don't
know is a particular viscosity
elasticity min Nursery of the objects
have to handle and I have to basically
parameterize in very quickly but I think
as you're very young what you're
learning about is the structure of
objects you have to interact with and in
fact we've got some evidence that when
you learn parameters you have a
difference
ten course for learning a single
exponential compared to when you learn
more complicated things which tend to
have double Exponential's as are you
learning structures and parameters at
the same time I don't want you to go
away thinking there's no way you can
store opposing things that was storing
opposing things when you've got no other
queues and of course you could give
people queues when they have these
different opposing perturbations so
here's a typical example here you can
have people hold a robot and the robots
gonna produce forces which backed at
right angles to the direction of motion
and always are proportional and
magnitude to the speed of the movement
so called curl for force field and I
have to give credit to MIT to never
Hogan and Emilio beat sleepy the first
people I believe to build these robots
and retransform a lot of the work we do
by allowing us to produce this complex
robotic state-dependent forces so these
are very nice you can produce this and
what you can do is on random trials you
can randomly ultimate between the right
and left on each trial just randomly
choose right or their force fields and
you can even tell people when this cue
is on here you're gonna get a right
force field and when this one's on
you're gonna get a left with Foster okay
so they have all the information they
need and what you find is before the
perturbation come on they're basically
accurate this is the deviation from a
straight line the force work comes on
and over the course for our they
basically they're nothing at all okay so
you can't learn stuff just when you're
told it or when you have a visual cue
and in fact even theirs look like a bit
of learning this is just stiffening up
because when we turn off unexpectedly
there's no after effect but a number of
years ago when Scott and colleagues
showed that if you do something before
half a second before you can get a small
amount of learning and we return to
explore this in a bit more detail so the
question is does the lead into a
movement help you separate motor
memories so now we have people start at
the left or right target they move in
dwell here for a pixel amount of time
and then move through the force world
there's no force field on this initial
movement
force in the second movement but the
direction of force was totally predicted
by when you move in from the left or the
right and in different groups of
subjects they have to draw between zero
and a thousand milliseconds if you move
in and have to wait a thousand
milliseconds you get almost in their
learning
she's stiffening up a little bit if you
only wait half a second you get very
little learning similar to the wainscot
study if you have to wait 150
milliseconds you get substantial
learning and if you'd have to wait at
all you get really impressive learning
so effectively what you do in about the
500 milliseconds before a movement is
really critical for how you could access
separate motor memories actually a very
strong cue to separate motor memories
now this was interesting to ask for a
particular reason because it leads me on
to think about a problem which is always
bug me about following through in sport
when you play a ball sport and you make
contact with the ball or your releasable
you're told to matter follow through the
movement but yet anything you do after
you release talk make contact with the
ball can't affect the ball at all so
there's all these theories about what
its wear-and-tear its how you plan the
movement that matters but if we think
about it if the lead in determines which
mid memory we activate now could the
follow-through determine retro actively
the motor memory you have now and - the
idea is we're gonna ask people to make a
movement through the force field and
then without the fall sort of being on
with idea that either stop there no
follow-through group no follow-through
they move through the force field and
stop and they have a cue which tells
them which force were they're going to
get as a toddler but they just stop
there and now I flip the axes around
zero means no learning 100 means perfect
learning this group learns nothing at
all okay as we expect however if we have
a follow-through group who move through
the force field and then either go to
the left off of that or to the right and
the direction of the future movement
it's gonna Turman the force field we get
what we see now is substantial learning
so what you're gonna do after you've
done a skill has a huge effect on your
ability to separate the motor memories
for that skill so that's great if you
want to learn two different things but
normally when we're doing sport we want
to learn one thing the right golf swing
and so on so flipping it on its head
what it would mean is if you're learning
a single skill and you always make a
consistent follow-through you're going
to put that into one motor memory if on
the other hand for every movement you
make a different follow-through you're
going to be spending you're learning
across motor memories so the prediction
is one group of subjects do
system follow-through one does a
variable follow-through and what we
could predict is you should be faster in
this condition this is a very simple
task then there's no opposing force
field here and what we see here for the
red group which is our consistent
follow-through they're significantly
faster to learn this then the
inconsistent follow-through good okay
now by the end of half an hour so they
get to the same level it's not a very
difficult task to learn could these sort
of lead in and follow through who's
really account for real real-world motor
learning properties well we can ask that
by giving people what we thought was
going to be a very easy task to learn
okay we're gonna give people a lead-in
and a follow-through and the skill
they're gonna get will depend on both
the lead in the follow-through so they
start from one of these two starting
locations they can end up one of these
two target locations they know that for
each trial and they get a force field
between these two via points and the
direction the force field depends on the
start location target location according
to the exclusive-or rules or non-renewal
so in this case if they go along the red
pass they get one force field they get
along the blue parsec at the other so
you can't predict which force we would
get based on where you start or where
you end it has to be the combination of
both em okay so should be very simple
thing to do we've been put in for five
days for an hour and a half a day and
over the course of those five days they
slowly learn this up to about 55% of for
learning so even for the simple task
much simpler than of a golf golf stroke
it takes a long time to learn to
separate these motor memories for
example based on leading the
follow-through and by the end of it we
see they're doing the appropriate things
for the four conditions about half and
the approval exclusive-or rule so it
suggests that what you activate now in
terms of motor memory depends on the
recent past about the 500 milliseconds
it probably depends on the recent future
we haven't mapped out the time course of
this would be very surprised if it
depends on further into the future in
the past it's a weaker effect the future
so as you move through time the recent
history has a huge effect on what you
store a motor memory so what would the
optimal follow-through be well if you
wanted to make the best photos through
it should be the watch as least variable
so you're storing things in the same
motor memory so you want to follow
through in a way that you can do
consistently that would be a sensible
thing to do so suggest that recent parts
of future actions determine the current
motor memory and allows
to separate out different motor skills
but a few minutes left
so I'm gonna shrink motor control down a
bit and getting dangerous territories
here because in all the tasks we do we
tell people here's the task you have to
do go do it but in reality unfortunately
they're these things called decisions
which come on top of all that which we
ignore in motor control we just think we
tell people what to do it's much easier
that way and so one question we can ask
is to what extent does the motor system
know about the decision-making system
there's these lovely models in
decision-making drift diffusion models
they're also lovely models are made
control Bob Moore feedback control but
they completely don't talk to each other
that completely separate models which
say you make a decision then I will take
over for the next bit for the movement
so often we think of it in this way I
accumulate evidence i watch a bunch of
dots the game are left or right I have
to keep it evidenced I hit a bound I
make a decision that's left my central
executive then said right let's do left
I plan the movement I execute it
that's one way to do it but the question
we want to address is could there be a
more continuous flow of information from
this decision process to the movement
process even before a decision has been
made and what we really want to do is
relate variables here so as you acute
care we call this room number the
decision variable and how much evidence
you've accumulated two things which
optimal feedback control cares about
filling up reflex gains to fixate
control the muscles and so what we want
to do is if a task or in every trial we
can estimate both the decision variable
and the reflex gain and ask how they're
related to each other hopefully before a
decisions be made and to do that we have
a very simple experiment subjected one
of our robotic devices and they sit
there with a hand here and they watch
one of these random kinematic grams this
is a task where some of the doctor I
have many other between the elbow and so
in this case it's very easy trial
they're moving in the flexor direction
and your job is when asked to respond to
directing the dots by moving your hand
in that direction to the flexural
extensive time and the cue to move is
that we control the duration of stimulus
two things happen to tell you to move
one is the dots go off and the second is
at the same time the handle the robot
moves one centimeter in 80 milliseconds
so it's a very fast movement of the hand
and that sets up effectively an EMG
response here effectively sets up a
reflex fons to a stretch reflex and so
we're gonna measure the EMG of the
flexes to measure the strength of that
reflex response which is putting you
trying to pull you back in the flexion
direction you then respond with a which
probably think is and we tell you with
you're right or wrong and so we're gonna
use the behavioural data to try and work
out the decision variable and then we're
gonna use this data to work out the
reflex game so the way we do that is
here's the viewing duration which we
control and here's the difficulty of the
task the percentage of dots moving the
same direction from three percent very
hard 51 percent very easy
the longer you view for the better you
get and the higher the coherence or the
percentage of dots the better you do not
surprisingly now we can fit this data
with the one parameter model which is
very simple which says given the dots I
generate
they're noisy my brains noisy so I get a
Gaussian distribution with a mean that
depends on the coherence and there's a
single parameter with links that
coherence the mean of this Gaussian I
then integrate over the time and when
you cue me to respond if I've got
positive numbers I'm inflection flexion
movement if I got negative as an
extension movement and there's one
parameter so affected the decision
variable it's going to be normally
distributed some unknown K times like n
times time with a variance of time man
so if it in that one parameter model to
our data we can do a reasonably good job
of accounting for that data and that
means on any trial we can say what would
the decision variable distribution to be
on that trial we know the answer you
give so we can truncate it and take the
average of that truncated as I estimate
on that trial of your decision variable
we also want to get the reflex gain the
motion display comes on it goes off we
put erbium we look at this tiny amount
of time here 150 milliseconds or so and
we measure the EMG and not against with
details of how you process it but what
we actually get is a net measure of the
EMG in favor of the direction you're
going to make your decision okay when
you finish off okay so it's the reflex
gain in that direction okay and so
what's going to do is sum it up over the
three time periods this is the
monosynaptic stretch response which
shouldn't be adapted on these sorts of
timescales the medium latency and the
long
the response so now we get a measure
never eat wrong so what I want to plot
is the decision variable we think you
have in your head okay based on model
against the reflux gain we measure from
the smallest medication also zero yeah
as we increase it and what are the
possibilities well one possibility is
it's flat effectively in that you don't
turn on your reflex in the interesting
way into your cue to move you just wait
make the decision and then sequentially
decide then add another possibility
it means a certain amount of evidence
before you bother getting the motor
system involved and turning it on in
some way some Thresh will has to be
crossed before you get but we see
showing here in a single subject and in
our group data is that for the
monosynaptic once you watch like our
control it's flat that's what we
expected to be we can expect that to
adapt but even for the one at 45 to 75
milliseconds of the perturbation we see
a beautiful almost linear increase in
reflux gain as a function of position
variable from the very smallest amounts
of evidence you get on average you're
pushing your gain up and more than so
even for the long latency now there's no
reason this should be linear it should
be monotonically increasing for to make
sense but it suggests you're preaching
your motor system for the sort of
confidence you have in the decision
you're going to finally make why would
you bother doing this well it turns out
you get to the target faster by doing
this by pre treating your reflexes it
helps you get to the target quickly and
therefore saves you some time so we
think that a continuous flow from
decision processes to the skelita motor
system and effectively the CNS provides
decision press information to it about
the certainty of the upcoming tasks the
brain represents probabilistic internal
models we think calmness tomography is a
fun technique to use to extract high
dimension representations and suggest
but even for a very well learned task of
face recognition we have generative
models that learning structures in the
world is important time will tell
whether the few recent papers overturn
this idea how we're doing experiments
and tests at the moment we think
temporal context are really vital for
the way you access arm different
memories and that there's a strong
interaction of decision-making reflex
control I thank all my collaborators
here and my funders and thank you